[Música]
el sonido familiar de una sirena
antiaérea vuelva a sonar en los
suburbios del noreste de la ciudad
continúan los combates con las tropas
ucranianas montando ahora contra ataques
contra las fuerzas rusas atrincheradas
tras semanas sin avances el presidente
afirma que el ejército de su país ha
aceptado fuertes golpes a Rusia al
tiempo que pide que se reanuden las
negociaciones de paz
nuestras fuerzas armadas continúan
repeliendo los ataques del enemigo en el
sur del país en dumbás en la dirección
de la región de kiev al frenar las
acciones de Rusia en nuestros Defensores
están llevando a los dirigentes rusos a
una idea simple y lógica es necesario
hablar
en la ciudad portuaria de mariupol
asediada desde el mar de se han
registrado combates callejeros las
autoridades de la urbe afirman que
todavía hay que evacuar a unos 100.000
civiles los que quedan allí describen
los efectos de semanas de bombardeos
discriminados por parte de Rusia
sí la gente está muriendo por qué están
luchando porque no pueden decidir Cómo
dividir El Poder y nosotros estamos
sufriendo tras un mes de guerra Rusia
solo ha conseguido capturar una ciudad
importante el puerto de jerson en el mar
Negro donde según el pentágono
estadounidense las fuerzas ucranianas
están montando otra contraofensiva en un
intento de retomar el control ante la
perspectiva de un estancamiento y de las
crecientes pérdidas
Moscú parece estar cambiando sus
objetivos describiendo la primera etapa
de su llamada operación militar especial
como finalizada centrándose ahora en el
control de la región oriental de dombas
donde los separatistas los rusos han
estado luchando en una guerra de
secesión desde el año 2014